[Music]
We're doing something a little bit
different today. We're working over 300
goats. Got our hands full. We're going
to dive into some details of goat
ranching with the Pokeet family. Joe
Poke and his wife and their two
daughters doing something that's very
important. We're going to work their
goats today. Babies, Billies, nannies,
all of them. And they're going back out
in the pasture.
[Music]
Okay. Yeah.
[Applause]
[Music]
This kid right
here. This kid's already been working
together.
You got you running the gate. Okay.
So Kevin, my stepdad, and Joe Pokeet
work together for the Noble Foundation.
If you don't know a little about Kevin,
Kevin is the goat and sheep guy. Always
has been. been into the sheep and goats
business for uh probably ever since he
was a kid. Um and then Kevin does some
stuff with goats at the Noble Foundation
and works with Joe Poke. But this is Joe
and his wife's little side hustle about
a pound. Yeah.
They eat her up at cell.
If she If she's lame, I'll catch her.
She's just struggling with her horns.
Okay. Now, we know obviously there's a
huge difference between working goats
and bison. Definitely a lot more
hands-on experience when you're working
the goats, but honestly, it's not that
much different other than you're dealing
with a,000 lb animal versus anywhere
from 60 to 100 lb animal. It's same sort
of process. So once we kind of corral
the goats and get them from one big pin
to a smaller pin and even into another
smaller pin from there is where you have
to sort the nannies away from the kids.
All of these goats today are getting
proper vaccinations just like we would
when we're working the bison. So, if
we've got calves, they're going to get a
couple of different vaccinations that
those are one time vaccinations for
their whole life, such as black leg.
Oh, I can handle that.
Yeah, we got we got
these baby goats are getting the same
thing. So that's why they're kind of
separated. And also most of the mills um
are going to get banded. And this is
part of the meat industry in goats. And
so this is pretty standard uh when you
have when you're working females and
males. The boys, if you're not selling
them for a breeding goat, then they're
going to be used on the meat side of
things. obviously for grazing and stuff
which is what the pes are doing in this
but in order to make a profit off your
animals you've got to either sell some
for breeding or meat and in this case
this area of the United States the goat
meat and hair sheep meat is becoming
very popular and is a growing industry.
So, just as a farmer raising crops or a
bison rancher raising bison, you've got
to be able to pay your bills, pay for
your fencing or feed or any of that.
You've got to be able to sell some
animals to make a profit to pay those
bills. And it doesn't matter how many
animals you have, whether it's 300 or
you have 10.
Okay. So, I don't know anything about
the ear cutting. It's just male. Female.
Oh boy. I wasn't sure either. Male,
female. I don't have a I didn't get my
tags in time. I would have tagged them,
but then I know cuz we're going to have
another flock of them here. Yeah. So
then I know which way we work these
ones. Yeah. And so what? Left ears. Left
ear. Left ear is female and right ear is
male. Okay. Is that right? It's a thing.
It's a thing. That's the way the doies.
You want to pet this? Okay.
Nice to meet you.
What do you think, Brooks? They work
good. They're cute, aren't they? So
cute. Don't touch that. It's a owie.
Two or three times.
So cute. How old? Oh gosh. Probably like
a couple weeks. Okay. Yeah. Or wait, is
this the umbilical part? Oh, yeah.
Probably a week. A week. I was going to
say they're small. They're so tiny. No,
I like this one. I just They don't like
This is more wormer.
It's a It's a different worm than what
we're given before. Okay. I get a
different class of worms in them.
Gotcha.
That's Is it targeting one specific?
Probably, but I don't know.
Well, I wouldn't either.
So,
Feisty little sister here. Yeah.
Might do hurt too. And
yeah.
black or that big do. It's the big
black. No, I think it's the big dough.
This one right here. Yeah, it's that
big.
Just her feet are pretty. You want to
look at her feet or No, just her
[Music]
Yeah, I go ahead.
Yeah, let's just put a
little I This one doesn't work. Third
time down here.
He's like
Yeah, I don't think it's going to get
out. But that's a we need that other So,
what did you just give her, Kevin? Sore
mouth vaccine. Sore mouth. And then
that's just a dewormer. No, no, no, no,
no, no. That from here is a great angle.
You can see the sorting of the nannies
versus the kids.
As you can see here, it's very important
to have good equipment, a good handling
facility so you're able to sort out your
animals in a efficient way. Nannies,
Billies, kids, and you can work them
properly and then let them back out into
the pasture. These animals are not in
here for very long and they're being
handled in a short amount of time. Just
like in the bison industry, you've got
to have good equipment. And Joe here set
up the pins perfectly and I think
everything went great. C and D, which is
for clustial peripheres. C and D. This
one actually does B and tetanas. Mhm.
All the above. All the above. Okay. B is
like overeating disease. Okay. C is
like uh
what's type C? I can't remember. Oh,
it's like a like a sour gut thing, I
think. I can't. Yeah, it has. I can't I
know D knee is like overeating. Yeah, D
is overeating and then the tea is just
straight. Used to everybody give
straight. Now they mix. You can still
buy. Oh, you're good. I was just
listening
to
straight kill.
So, they will get that now in the
spring. Will you redo it like in the
fall?
Probably not.
Just depends like so we do it now. So
hopefully they pass a little bit
immunity to the bread ones. Okay. Cuz a
lot of these hopefully are bred to kid
here in another two months. So we want
to give it to them now. That way the
kids can get it and then when we
vaccinate the kids it's they're a little
more protected against it. Sure. Unless
claustrdia isn't everything like it's
everywhere. And so I don't know is
that's like a that's that's what we're
vaccinating for is the claustrdia
peripheres and there's different strains
of it and it's like just lives in the
soil. It's everywhere. It's not
everybody has it. It's in your gut
microb, you know, microfllora and stuff,
but when you get stressed or if you have
a inflammation of some kind, then it'll
take it's a bacteria. It'll take over
and cause problems. Gotcha. Gotcha. Did
you do this one already, Jesse? Yes,
sir.
[Music]
Golly.
Kevin lease pokeet some of these billies
and they can spread their love. It just
be like Big Joe being rented and going
to somebody else's property. Same thing.
This is just another way to make a
profit off your animals. You can
actually rent or lease out your billies
and other producers can use those
billies. Different genetics, different
breeds for their own benefit.
Needs a little WD40, I'd say.
[Music]
Oh, here
he goes inside.
[Music]
by the door.
I got
[Music]
ready.
Isa, you want to let them out? Did you
give them this? The two little ones.
Little ones. Were those worked? Yeah,
they already had 10. I think they got
worked already. Okay. They're the
They're the escape artists, I think.
Right.
[Music]
Open it up. Open it up. Open it up.
Okay.
She's so funny. She says well.
[Music]
Mom.
Mom. Help me. No.
All right, here it is. The last big
group of goats that are going to work
today. Kind of takes a team effort on
something like this. Instead of using a
pusher like we would for the bison,
obviously way more dangerous situation
when working bison. But as far as the
goats, just kind of coring them and
pushing them and funneling down into a
smaller pin and obviously into another
smaller pin. Same thing that we would do
with bison. Goats will be goats. And if
there's one animal I would compare bison
to. I compare them to goats all the
time. As far as behavior goes, they're
just so curious. They're so
nosy. Just like a goat. I think bison
are just as nosy.
[Music]
trying to find his little
turn the whole way and then straightened
up in the
I'll just ask. Okay. So, Joe's here and
one of the questions that I think is
important uh for me, people have talked
to me about using, you know, we have our
bison and they're after the grasses. One
of the things that people always mention
is using goats for cleanup that the
bison don't eat. Can you talk about
multiecies grazing? Joe does this
full-time already for the Noble
Foundation and then as a side hustle,
too. So, I mean, he's got a lot of
experience. So, what what's your opinion
of of the using the goats? So, I'm
fairly new to goats, too, only in the
last 3 or 4 years, but you can see
pretty quickly the impact they have on
the land. And the good thing is a lot of
this land hasn't had goat impact, so
it's really primed for it. and they they
would prefer to eat the brows and the
forbes and you know leave the grass. So
when we mix that with a large room like
bison or cattle or something it the
symbiosis the nature symbiosis is
apparent. You know it's it's pretty
obvious. So at this place here we've got
at least we there's a lot of a lot of
brush that we're trying to beat it back
a little bit. So we're stocked pretty
aggressively but that's on purpose to
help open some of this up and then of
course we let everything have adequate
rest to grow back. So the way it's split
now, this is kind of the open half and
then the wooded half is over there. So
we graze them over here in the winter.
And then what's been really cool and we
should go I go take you around and look
at it. But what's really cool here is in
the winter we just had this rested for
an entire summer. So there's a lot of
dead native grass. But the little three
and fourt tall cedars, there's nothing
left of them. They destroyed every one
of them. Yeah. Well, you can even look
right here behind you. Oh yeah. And you
can see what four or five feet tall.
There's no green underneath those trees.
And it's not because I mean we're pretty
early into spring too, but this is
that's the browse line. Yeah. And right
now I usually have them a little more
fenced in. Right now we're just trying
to get around everything very fast. So
they have a big area which is not how we
manage it normally, but just the kind of
context we're right now. So they kind of
get this and they get to pick at the
brush over there and there's not enough
just to lock them on it. So yep. But
they're getting all this really emerging
stuff. And you're absolutely right.
They're there. Definitely a browse line
here. And that's only from, you know,
the 30 days the brush has been growing.
That's crazy. Yeah. And the cedar tree
thing, too, is like bison will they're
not going to eat it, but they're going
to whip it so bad and they can break it
and it eventually die. But a goat's
going to come through and gnaw on those
those things. And once they lose their
needles, they're I mean, they're dead.
They're going to die. And and and they
the goats really prefer that in the
winter time. It compliments their diet.
You know, there's a lot of tannins in
cedar, too, and that helps kind of with
the parasites, keeping them clean and,
you know, healthy. So, you we can I can
Let's go over my truck and I'll show you
some stuff. Show you. Yeah. And there's
definitely some cedar trees that they've
killed just from eating all the needles.
But, too, some of the bigger ones,
they've rung the run the bark and done
the cadium cadmium or cad can't
remember, but they get in that layer of
the bark and that that's going to kill
that tree. Kills it too. Yeah,
absolutely. And we're not trying to kill
all the trees, but no, this is a a
jungle. It's kind of unmanageable. So
goats can open that up and we can, you
know, we might have to do some
mechanical intervention to open the
canopy up to get some more native
grasses growing because, you know,
ideally we're in the cross timbers eco
region, right? So we want this to be a
cross timber savannah. Yes. Scattered
trees and lots of grass. And they're
going to help you get they're going to
help you clean it up enough where you
can see, okay, we need to get in here
with maybe a skid steer. That's right.
You know, and and do that. So, so the
other thing is to me I think the goat
thing is becoming a more approachable
side hustle and maybe full-time for some
people. Um, not only if it's multiecies
species grazing, but it they're just
they're they can be difficult like
keeping them in your fence, but no
different than bison. Keep them happy
and fed, watered, all those things. But
just you know, like it's a business.
It's a little side business now. And I
think it's more approachable
um now because I think more people are
saying, "Hey, you can use these animals
to clean up your property." And as long
as you got good fencing and all those
things, keep them happy, you can run a
business off of it. That's right. And
you know, the way things are today with
the barrier to entry to getting started
in agriculture is really, really high.
Right. Yep. Mostly capital. But you
know, we're we're first generation
ranchers and we've been doing this
professionally. I've been doing it
professionally for somebody else for
over 20 years. So, we're not new by any
means, but we're still first generation
trying to make our make our run at it.
And I always get always thinking saying
like you got to be willing to do what
other people aren't willing to do. Yep.
And lots of people would rather just
have cows and I want to have a ranging
business. Yeah. So, if the goats are
going to help us do that and it wasn't
without it work, you know, somebody told
me that you get paid to learn how to
keep goats in. And I always thought that
was funny because I' I've spent more
time working on the fence here. Yeah. I
mean, there was four or five months of
just working on the fence even bothering
us and but knowing just from my
experience at work, too. Just knowing
that that was important. Yeah. Don't
have to be chasing them around.
Absolutely. I want to show you a couple.
Yeah. I want to Well, I want to get
some. Of course, cedars. They all know
that. They all know that I hate cedar
trees. Yeah. Let's go. Let's get my
truck and I'll go show you. Okay. Let's
go look at them.
that has just been gobbled up. Like
there's nothing left of those
cedars. Nothing
left. And now that tree instead of
having I don't know 8 n 10 cedar trees
taking water, you've got a big one big
oak tree oak tree that can can get some
more water and it creates a better
habitat for whether turkeys want to
roost there or not. Yep. Haven't got up
there high enough. But if they need to,
they could stand up, push that thing
over, and eat it. I've watched them do
that if they have
to. That's pretty cool. Little one in
the back. They were barking that one.
Yeah. So, they are knocking the bark off
of it. That is so
cool. Yeah, that's good stuff. So, this
is something that a bison will not do.
They do not won't browse off these type
of trees, but what a bison will do is
rub and rub and rub it. Rub until
they're all broke and then they snap and
then they're dead. Yeah, it looks ugly
for a while until it rots away, but
yeah, all of those right here under this
big old oak tree. Pretty cool. Yep,
there is.
All them cedars. Look at all those
cedars. Yeah. And they're ripping the
bark off that one over there. Yeah.
Yeah. So, and that was really good feed
this winter for them. Absolutely.
Balances the gut and they're getting
what they need. And then I guarantee you
before you put these goats in there, you
couldn't see that green grass on the
other side. Oh, for sure you could. This
was all completely covered and now
wildlife can go in and out of there
100%. Yep. We're big on on deer habitat,
too. And Yep. You can go over here on
stuff that doesn't have a goat in
So here, this is what we'd call more
than likely field fence. Starts out low
or it starts out small here and it gets
bigger as you get to the top. And this
one is only going to be 36 in tall, 3 ft
up here on the side of my hip. This is
your typical goat
fence. And
As long as you got plenty of forge, you
keep them happy. They don't need to jump
over anything. Could also keep predators
out as well, I
think. You think this helps
uh keep coyotes out? Yeah, you can find
them. So, like here, little crawl
spaces. This was a this is just a wash,
but I put a log in there, you know.
Yeah. But goats will get out there, too.
So, yeah, they will. across the fence.
You can see the Yeah, that's a good way
to look at
it. So, this
is
obviously Joe's. Look at
this. All of the
growth, all the
underbrush. You I mean, you can't see
through there at all. And then you come
over
here and I you can see 30 40 yards in
there to the other side. You can see the
browse line and this is only 4 months
having them in here. Four months, you
know. Yeah. Not continuously. They they
grazed this in December and then they've
had access access to it now for probably
the last two weeks. So, it's had a
little bit of rest, but yeah, definitely
definitely a major difference between
the two sides.
Absolutely. Yeah, you can see all the
way through there. That's so cool. Yeah,
we just saw a goat and deer can see
that. And yeah, pigs and or whatever
else, you know, whatever wildlife you
want. Turkeys, quail. I mean, they're
more determined to run through some of
this stuff now. Yeah. And forage and
Well, they have a chance to. I mean,
they can pick their way through that,
but it's just kind of a a jungle.
Yeah. I mean, I wouldn't want to go
through that. Yeah. Me either. So,
yeah. This looks awesome. Looks really
good. Something I've learned about the
bison, too, in places like this. I was
like worried, do I need goats? Do I need
to put goats in some of our um brushy
areas or our tree lines? You know,
thought about doing that. But what the
bison have done is they're just big and
broad and don't care. They just
bulldoze. They just bulldo through there
and you you'd be surprised they'll go
through and nip at stuff for sure, but
they'll just blow through there and
create and open it up. It's kind of
surprising. So So the next issue we have
is we can see what's going on here now,
but there's still not very much sunlight
getting through the canopy. So, like all
these little trees, we're just gonna
have to come in here mechanically and
open open the canopy up. Yeah. You know,
you leave the big and Yeah. Leave the
big oaks and pecans and stuff like that.
But Yeah. And so, traditionally, all the
unullet would have handled that way back
when. That's right. But when you put a
fence up and then you don't manage it,
you take away from, you know, what
nature would have been doing hundreds of
years ago. take the unullet away and
then all the shrubby stuff that a a deer
or an analopee that were here back in
the day or elk and y bison would have
wouldn't have let any of this stuff
happen and then you don't manage it and
then here's what happens or fire too or
fire. Yeah, that's I was fixing to say
like these big these are big honey
locust and stuff and yeah, they're
they're good they can be good fodder for
wildlife too but they'll take over an
area pretty easy too. fast. They'll do
it fast. They can be invasive. Yeah. So,
you when you put a fence up, all that
changes if you don't manage it. But I
would almost guarantee you that this was
all peanuts or cotton at some time. Oh,
I mean, look how big these oak trees
are. Yeah. There's not big oak trees
like that out in the middle. And then
there's a lot of there's old wheel line
wheels here and all aluminum pipe. So,
you know, this wasn't always a forest.
Like, that's the main argument is like,
well, you're letting nature go back to
what nature wants to do. This was
probably plowed in the 30s and 40s. It
was peanuts. Yep. You know. Yep. Yeah.
There are some big trees in here. And
then over
time it can happen. Yep. This is what
this is how it goes. And so you just got
the deer or whether the hogs too that we
have now, but all the analopee are gone,
all the bison are gone, all the elk are
gone. And so you can kind of follow up
or add in the goats and this is what you
get. That's right. I like it. Thanks,
Joe. Yeah, it's good stuff.
That is a big old tree in there. Is that
a pecan? Is it? I've never looked very
close at it. Look at
her. Little fresh set right
there. Little bitty
Brooks. Well, Brooks, Marissa, and I
want to personally thank the Poke family
for inviting us out to do a little goat
ranching today. I hope you guys learned
something new about goat ranching. I
know it's a little bit different than
biceing, but it's great to compare those
species and you can kind of imagine the
same thing the goats can do and what the
bison can do and what those type of
animals were doing historically on the
great plains. You can thank all the
unullet, goats and bison, deer, elk, and
all of them that kept the great plains
wide open and full of native grasses. I
want to thank them for letting us a
video today and showing their operation
and what they do. Great people, great
little family. I love what they're
doing. Thank you guys for watching us.
We'll see you guys soon. and rankable
boss ranchion.